tu vas arrêter de fumer
ouais c'est quoi ce bouquin stefan zweig
ouais ça je connais stéphane zag mais
c'est quoi mon tel contexte ce n'est pas
la grande théorie de montagne j'ai pas
fais voir je vais dire c'était un truc
comme ça c'était celui qui pensent
librement pour lui de même en or toute
liberté sur sa terre ah bon d'accord
c'est ma théorie moi c'est à l'usap
était libre penseuse je suis une petite
culturel
peut-être une petite jauge pour cultiver
tué staples hey tu vas bien remplie oui
ce n'était pas tant enfin là je contiens
de quoi je me relis je me poitras oui
mais tu sais qu'il faut que tu arrêtes
de faire de la télé vous avec tuner
impôts quand même avec j'écrive que je
vise mais tu écris vincent chautard
bah si c'est bien ça le bras je rends
les livres moi ça lui annonce avec toi
on va y aller là oui ça l'est au bon
disque au fond thiamine center cisco et
mines
waouh olivier minne ccsi fait le
commentaire
elle est bien un bel et bien rester mais
audience aurait fait voilà pour draguer
tellabs enregistrés chez les tutsis mais
l'embouteillage un grand jeu démarre
bien je suis fasciné que tu lis
qu'est-ce qui remercie on va y aller là
chantal on y va où j'allais faire
l'animateur télé malade qu'est ce que je
fais moi aujourd'hui
petit je commence mon quart d'entre eux
allez c'est bon je reprends mon avocat
cet homme a décidé de prendre tous les
risques
tous les samedis soirs il va relever un
formidable défi vous tenir en haleine
pendant une heure pour vous empêcher de
zapper et conserver son audimat
il est prêt à tout tous les moyens sont
bons même la qualité
les
bah
m
viens de
sur le plateau d'art dima je sais que
bon nombre d'entre vous seront très
étonné de voir mon visage ainsi masqué
parce qu'en termes professionnels ou
nommant une mosaïque mais là comme un
accord avec la direction de la chaîne
nous avons décidé de lutter contre cette
mise en valeur excessive des vedettes de
télévision que l'on dénonce à juste
titre dans vos journaux
je crois que face à cette scandaleuse
tarification il était temps de réagir
halte au nombrilisme hardy matt l'a fait
je vais mater
je vais maintenant vous rappeler les
principes de mon émission pendant un peu
plus d'une heure vous allez voir des
documents exceptionnels que j'ai choisis
pour vous j'espère qu'ils seront vous
plaire car comme on vous l'a assez
répété si vous zappez je suis viré je
sais je sais que beaucoup d'entre vous
verrez la chose sans trop de regrets
notamment monsieur georges chossat
donnant milhas ap
vous connaissez tous zappe
je sais que les français aiment beaucoup
les animaux
moi aussi un bon petit japonais il est
joli hein ah il est très joli très bien
mais très bien toile était un bon petit
à pune vous avez compris s'il a redit
mme à descendre sous de 15%
j'habite le club s'est vu un bon petit
zappe
alors soyez gentils et regardez mon
émission jusqu'à la fin du jeu avec moi
le professeur rollin bon sens pas en
reste puisqu'une remarque mettez-y un
petit peu plus de nerfs vous abonner à
moitié endormi ce soir vous avez pour
faire de l'audimat il faut que ça
swingue
ouais mais jean-pierre mais
téléspectateur moyen alors comment ça va
bien très bien
finale open raoui toujours fidèle qui
rien mais pourtant c'est ça a été
difficile parce que maintenant on est
assez demandée avec jean-pierre on a
vraiment fait des pieds et des mains
pour se libérer enfin bon merci d'être
là oui on avait un dîner avec paul paul
qui paul wermus cestari fille de passer
la télé sais pas vous mais on s'est
débrouillé quand même on a tout fait
pour venir pour pas vous laisser tomber
pour être là ce soir encore on est là
c'est l'essentiel vous pouvez commencer
les mini merci
vous ne pouvez pas dire un coffret dans
ce dans ce studio non c'est vrai oui est
ce qu on pourrait avoir la température
du studio sandrine
[Applaudissements]
120 des listes
une vraie star désormais sandrine
combien fait-il qu'il y va il fait 21 2
à 1
il fait chaud c'est 21 est ce qu'on
pourrait faire un petit bilan de l'est
naturellement thierry c'est la tradition
et c'est prévu
ce petit bilan est là je dois une
nouvelle fois vous tirer mon chapeau
vous ment boucher un coin la séquence
terry qui a fait le meilleur score la
semaine dernière c'est celle de michael
jackson dans thriller
[Applaudissements]
c'est un extraordinaire vous aviez
mission entre nicole croisille où
michael jackson est là avec un flair
incroyable avec un pif désormais
légendaire vous avez choisi michael
jackson s'est on peut dire vraiment vous
avez mérité cette fameuse médaille de
grand pif du paf qui vous avait été
décerné la semaine dernière parce
qu'autant les 7 d'or dont tout le monde
sait bien que c'est truqué en faveur du
service public ça vaut rien le grand pic
du pape qui arrive vous l'avez vraiment
mérité mais si on le regardait chantal
se remplissent du paris saint germain
heures debout remettre au nom du peuple
français
le pif du paf merci pour la bonne idée
que vous avez eue la semaine dernière
mulroney une fois merci
bref les i
parce que peut nous à moi c'est la
télévision de a jusqu'à z
et oui c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
on savait ce qui est désolant mairie
savez ce qui est désolant c'est que d'un
côté avec ce genre de trouvaille vous
nous fait gagner de l'audience
et puis de l'autre va vous allez faire
le zozo place de la concorde et piper
nous fait peur c'est gagné ce n'est pas
un bon calcul de la boulangerie croyez
moi alors qu'elle grandit dès cette
semaine pour essayer de rattraper le
temps perdu
je me suis dit jackson c'est n'aurait-il
pas de la famille 1 ça c'est le flair ça
vous est venu comment cette idée la
tuerie je te restaurant avec ma femme et
je regarde ma femme et je me dis non et
il pas de la famille vous mangiez quoi
sans indiscrétion convient peut-être
d'agneau dans un restaurant mardi
oui encore voilà j'ai trouvé qu'il avait
une soeur une dénommée janet janet
jackson génial hein
jackson nastic libye
[Musique]
la politique intérieure française à un
retour en force à la une de l'actualité
fort de son non-lieu dans l' affaire qui
l'opposé au député rpr tranchant est
redevenu aussitôt ministre de la ville
bernard tapie songe à se présenter dans
la 4e circonscription de marseille nous
le voyons ici goûter les joies d'un
dimanche ensoleillé dans la capitale
phocéenne
je te jure
pendant ce temps
sein de la coalition udf rpr donnée
gagnante dans les sondages
l'ambiance est au beau fixe ici edouard
balladur et françois léotard qui lui n'a
toujours pas eu son non-lieu règle les
derniers détails du code de bonne
conduite
concernant l'accession de l'un d'eux au
poste de premier ministre d'un
gouvernement de cohabitation président
malgré sa participation au très bel
hommage consacré lundi dernier par
france 2 au chanteur michel berger
malgré sa présence au dîner annuel de
sos racisme
malgré la légion d'honneur remise à
michel sardou force est de constater
qu'il s'effondre dans les sondages
[Musique]
non non non stop stop tirer le procédé
est un peu lassant à la fin on a compris
le système vous procédez par allégorie
c'est ça les crocodiles le parti
socialiste c'est un petit peu court en
réalité vous n'avez pas le courage de
montrer les hommes politiques tels
qu'ils sont pas là la vérité en 1981
vraiment de pardon suivez au quotidien
la campagne du candidat jacques chirac
le film s'appelait reporter la réalité
ne manque pas de cruauté vous allez
j'ai dit bizarre voilà un plaisir est
installée ici
ah oui vous n'était pas un pari par une
soirée parce qu'il est
mais pas très cher pendant une heure
loin des regards des artistes emmènent
saint dominique dans la scène régionale
les aiglons ne sont pas en bon état
on verra comment
journée
j'aurai dans la misère
mieux
là encore ça c'est un ami d'enfance
également à la filiale il y avait le
plaisir doit rencontrer ici qu'est ce
que je peux
possible
la pl
jean bien je me sentais pas tout autre
marque dacia sont pas méchants bonjour
monsieur saison messieurs mais super il
s'assure vêtements les félicitations des
avanchets événements de produits
félicitations d'obama est un coquin oui
ça paie
merci jeudi l'accord des travaux
présentés à tout le mandat
oui y avoir une maison peugeot assad
et vous croyez à tout le monde mais non
non je crois ce que je vois
bonjour monsieur le maire monsieur
écoutez ci dessus des profs du présent
c'est qu'on y ajoute le super bien
manger comment vous avez envie d'en
manger 0 60 ans dans dix minutes je vais
me couper un peu et c'est à l'envi
refaite mois ferme groupe prodware
pendante haïk un abonné en main au
bouton et sans poussière aller sans vie
vous avez échangé au revoir monsieur
madame un waf trois dames
[Musique]
la maison est bonne bonne qualité et
bonne humeur
c'est le cas c'est un gage de sérieux
mais non mais non tueur il avoue passer
d'un extrême dans l'autre vous passez de
l'allusion allégorique au réalisme plat
maintenant ou et la créativité là dedans
c'est pas une émission salon 1980 le
candidat valéry giscard d'estaing avait
perdu les élections
son départ du palais présidentiel
marquera l'entrée en force de la
politique spectacle à l'elysée
ce document a redit matelas retrouvé
pour vous c'était le 19 mai
181 regarder je souhaite que la
providence veille sur la france pour son
bonheur pour son bien et pour sa
grandeur au revoir
[Musique]
je vois toujours pas l'intérêt ah bon
non
je vois toujours pas l'intérêt à thury
et maintenant hardy matt vous propose
avec we semaine d'avant sur toutes les
autres émissions de télé un document
exceptionnel sur le retour de la droite
aux affaires
attention ceux qui vont rater ça pour en
l'air treck au bureau lundi matin
[Musique]
et terry seignosse ne convient que c'est
mieux même salle et de la politique là
ça nous a fait perdre toute notre
clientèle de jeunes les jeunes se
foutent complètement de la politique
alors je crois qu'il faudrait redresser
la barre c'est pas grave en faire du
comique
excusez moi celles ci ont changé les
français je crois ne pas bien compris
comment ça fonctionne alors il faut le
savoir il n'y a pas une bourse mais deux
il y à là bourse au comptant et la
bourse à terme que l'on collé mois et au
milieu de ces deux bourgs il y à un
organe régulateur qui se dressent
lorsque le marché est trop excité
pour éviter le crash alors cet organe
régulateur on l'appelle le 4/4 qu'est ce
que le 4k allons vous dire ça c'est une
espèce de grosse carotte que l'on agite
devant les petits porteurs
pour éviter qu'ils samba dirais pour les
petits porteurs comme vous et moi la
bourse quel intérêt je n'irai attention
je n'ai pas la taille du portefeuille
qui compte c'est la valeur du 4k car si
le cac 40 est mou les raiders quitte les
bourses les petits porteurs s'affolent
ils vendent tout et les bourses
c'est fou sur les marchés financiers
et ça fait mal hein
musique
[Musique]
oui
ouais
non
[Musique]
comme actionnaire
gros bisous
on verra
oh
[Applaudissements]
thierry thierry maire de quoi emmerdes
by écrire un spectacle et toi tu mets
une minute
j'ai pas le temps - eh ben tu vois pas
le temps mais l'émission a fait une
heure tu es gentil c'est jamal que j'en
passe une nuit et j'entends ça fait des
années que vous coupez vous saucisses et
ce qu'on veut mais oui vous allez vous
voulez parce que les attend est ce que
tu pourrais comprendre que vous êtes des
tueurs
vous êtes des tueurs d'artistes de
comics du mourillon veut surtout pas des
tueurs de chiens ici hockey quand vous
aurez le pouvoir vous finirez tous
pareil parce que la télé c'est pas pour
faire un reproche mais juste un petit
c'est trop c'est trop de découpe et de
ceux-ci sonnait comme sale et l'extra il
est supérieur pas l'histoire ou ne s'est
pas fait rouler bien qu'il est déprimé
ou non
kekel sketch bas le sketch par mois je
vais le dire comme dutronc viens viens
faire via vient faire le truc sur scène
avec moi moi je suis chez moi
[Applaudissements]
à boucoiran un boulanger des ridicules
pour avoir l'air ridicule parce qu hors
contexte ça voudra rien dire
c'est très sympa le passé un extrait
mais bordel fait un effort mais quels
étaient les trucs jusqu'au bout j'ai pas
mais une heure et demie de sketches un
truc comme ça c'est trop long voilà ce
que je peux dire c'est l'enfer faisant
la boue thierry je te montre un exemple
quoi faire un bout de sketches mégarde
césar du meilleur dictateur 1992 sont
nominés saddam hussein et nos riches à
necker voilà j'ai trois fois plus de
rire quand je le fais en face il y en a
deux qui sont minces non mais pourquoi
faire plus de rire parce que c'est le
contexte laïcité le roi tu es chez toi
et moi j'avais fait un truc hors du
contexte regardant comme ça mais regarde
la tête de l'autre qu'est ce que tu veux
que je fasse en cette saison de trois
ans cyril even nous embobiner cet
homme-là nom alors je vous emmerde ça va
c'est maintenant je vous emmerde way et
ben je me casse ça roule
[Applaudissements]
pourtant j'ai quand même fait un peu
intello non quand même nom mais il
faudrait des sujets sur la mode je
voulais déjà dit la semaine dernière
vous voulez pas m'écouter les choses qui
intéressent les femmes en ski comme moi
je vais vous dire s'ils voulaient
remonter la pente
ce qu'il faudrait diffusé maintenant
c'est un match de basket dis pas ça je
parle en mon nom je parle au nom des
millions de téléspectateurs que je
représente ici un ce qu'ils veulent voir
moi je vous dise qu'ils veulent voir
maintenant les téléspectateurs c'est un
match de basket
jacques du foot football maintenant avec
jean pierre papin malheureux à milan où
il n'arrive pas à s'imposer
le célèbre footballeur affirmé être en
contact avec le paris saint-germain
une information aussitôt démentie par
michel denisot le président du club
parisien
c'est à se demander si pour canal+ papin
n'est pas plus rentable guignols de
l'info que sur la pelouse du parc des
princes
en attendant seul milan pas parler comme
vous ils regardent ça vous le rappelez
tous certainement le premier match
contre le canada c'était mon premier but
c'était
une ma première coupe du monde et ça
reste pour moi un des meilleurs
souvenirs de footballeur certainement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
la très bons souvenirs à montpellier
contre l'allemagne monfort jeu et se
pose comme question des pratiques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà le plus beau but celui contre
l'espagne je crois que chacun ressent
très remarquée à comme ça soulage des
réussi à l'équipe de france ses plus
beaux souvenirs avec une baisse car il y
en aura d'autres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tard hier star de la télé aujourd'hui
loi les caméras loin du coeur
la puissance et la violence de la
télévision dans le monde moderne sont
très bien illustré par un film de
stephen frears qui sort mercredi
prochain et qui s'appelle héros malgré
lui avec dustin hoffman
après my beautiful laundrette plus
quelques rires et sammy et rosie
s'envoient en l'air
stéphane ruiz refera très fort regardez
[Musique]
5 à tcc
m
[Musique]
coach aquitain
et du gala
size
regardez
or training camp de gbagbo
et pourquoi
durée 1 h 15
[Musique]
non
novelli
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
réaliser la dame du vendredi avec cary
grant et déjà ok voyez la presse comme
une machine à produire des secours la
scène que nous avons retrouvé d'ailleurs
étonnamment proche de celle du film
please vous allez voir une anomalie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
système maison
[Applaudissements]
mais jamais
tout est possible devant une caméra même
les faux témoignages la preuve
jean yves lafesse est-ce que vous avez
vu ce qui s'est passé ici à 11h30 dire
maintenant je vous explique on est pour
le journal de 13 heures il ya un enfant
qui est tombé du 7e étage
sa mère l'a lâché bon je tenais là comme
ça s'amuser à faire c'est mon etc
l'enfant est tombé dans l'arbre la a été
sauvée oui mais le problème c'est que
nous n'avons que témoin est ce que vous
pouvez
je vous explique ce qui s'est passé dans
ce vignoble 20 mai rue de la croix sur
la venue me voir regarder que c'est pas
grave
[Applaudissements]
donc
l'enfant est tombé dans cet arbre ici je
sais pas si vous imaginez de là à là
c'est la merde cv la mère faisait ça
comme ça et il est tombé là il a été
sauvé miraculeusement dans l'arbre est
ce que vous pouvez dire que vous passez
et que vous avez vu ce qui se passe non
pas vu mais ça l'est parce que nous nous
manque le témoin le journal 'de à passer
au journal de 13 heures 8 simplement bon
voilà ce qui s'est passé effectivement
j'ai passé j'ai entendu un cri j'ai vu
la mer là chez l'enfant
il est tombé là je les prie j'ai déposé
et c'est pas faute et maintenant d'abord
ce ne sera pas la police a annoncé qu'un
fumeur mais je serai bien vous éclater à
toi une chaîne télévision nous
travaillons fait et nous on y va mais ça
me paraît quand même bizarre de partis à
balcons là et d'acquérir les regards du
7ème étage l'enfance est un mot français
une plume à l'enfoncer une plume
monsieur ah oui mais faut quand même le
lancer ce qu'elle a fait boum et
s'amuser là vous avez de l'armée un mot
- 8 mai dans ce rôle alors la mer est
hystérique a été sous contrôle médical
elle a fait comme ça fait très vite et
on va partir je fais signer un registre
tout vous m'entendez on a quelqu'un qui
me le dire rapidement ce qui s'est passé
d'accord ok on y va rick d'un guerre
bonjour il est très simple nous sommes
en direct erika les témoins principaux
de la sphère dont plus nous pouvons
désormais qualifié de miracle en effet
tous les témoignages concordent
n'est ce pas monsieur vous veniez lequel
endroit l'immeuble se par le petit
portillon
je me dirigeais vers la milice fort pour
aller chercher mon pain vous êtes
entouré la crise je crois maintenant
bien cuit et j'ai pas vu exactement de
quelles valeurs on sale mène enfin
l'enfant atterri dans un arbre qui se
trouvait place etienne pernet d'y
trouver dans quel arbre qu'est-ce que
j'ai fait des 100 vols enfin et ce n'est
venu rechercher un café
[Musique]
voici
voici maintenant un document
exceptionnel voici un extrait d'un
réchaud latino américains qui se termine
en main d'abord l'histoire d'une jeune
fille rendre à 15 ans s'est suicidé elle
s'est suicidé parce que sa mère marisa
la gifler en apprenant qu'elle était
enceinte
le jour où marisa vient se recueillir
sur la tombe de sa fille son mari emilio
pour qui elle est la responsable de la
mort de yoann draps l'attend avec un
revolver est il là bas à bout portant
mais la télé pourquoi est-elle là les
producteurs du reality-show savait-il
qu'il se passerait quelque chose ce jour
là trois yards
je le savais pas que
l'aviation est ok
petit hameau l'est tandis que les
annotations sont soit au moins sa
décision de quitter la ville
[Rires]
[Musique]
on
en 1982 un dénommé romano vend des
rebelles s'en sortait un film sans
acteur ni montage intitulé l'amérique
interdite
on y gagne et je veux pas
ok les bonnes
bravo jeudi un écoute pas moi qui était
au courant j'ai cru presque ça me tient
la série formidable un bien foutu grand
professionnel il a exercé comme plateau
ça marche toujours classé 9e c'est sûr
besser tous les vins fui dans le plateau
thierry sont bidonnés je crois que les
gens c'est un peu communs comme la
colique de l'ermite chez pivot là
c'était préparé des mois al avance le
gars qui est arrivé avec un couteau chez
pivot reste un comédien il s'appelle
jean-pierre grangé tout est bidonné
ppda dalle il paraît qu'ils l'ont répété
pendant une heure dans l'après midi
et naturellement c'est écrit à la
virgule fait c'est bien foutu c'est jack
là vous en étiez ou tirer mais j'en
étais en 1982 un dénommé romano
vanderbeek sortait un film sans acteur
ni montage intitulé l'amérique interdite
on y voyait un bordel pour chez des gens
habitant dans les égouts new yor
d'autres qui se nourrissait de vers de
terre et une pâtisserie qui d'une
pâtisserie érotique c'est bien pratique
pour parler de cul à cette heure là la
télé dans cette boutique attire un grand
nombre de femmes du monde qui viennent
régulièrement chercher leur bonheur
parmi un grand choix de pâtisseries
suggestives
m
[Musique]
dans un petit salon de thé attenante à
la pâtisserie ces dames bien sous tous
rapports se retrouvent pour goûter
[Musique]
il est amusant de remarquer que celles
qui sont généralement choqué par
certaines exhibition concrètes sont
parfaitement à l'aise quand le sexe est
offert à leurs convoitises
dans cette atmosphère chaude et sucrée
[Musique]
à
on
m
[Musique]
un toi t'es pas trop naze ça va c'est
long c'est chiant c'est ça la télé c'est
sa vie guillaume c'est un sinon lui de
raconter
c'est ce que c'est le pays oui mais si
vite un tas plus vite mais non mais je
peux être bien syriens quoi alors
sandrine vous aimez les gâteaux oui mais
les gourganes
nathan mesdames et messieurs nous allons
aller plus loin dans l'escaladé du sexe
et la télévision
s'il vous plaît éloignez les enfants oui
[Musique]
et allez c'est pas bien vous partez d'un
constat très intelligent vous dites les
gens veulent du sexe mais il suffit pas
de dire les gens veulent du sexe
il faut se demander précisément quand
veulent t'ils du sexe combien pourquoi
comment quel genre de sexe mais j'ai
demandé à bob bell en cas d'aller
enquêter dans la rue mouffetard voilà
tous les jours à quelle heure 20 heures
plus tôt ta antho après 11 heures une
fois que les enfants sont couchés c'est
mieux quand même 11 heures c'est bien
quel jour le dimanche et le jeudi avant
pendant ou après les repas peu importe
même pendant avant pendant après par
rapport après vient après pourquoi
pourquoi parce que ça gêne c'est quand
même pas des choses à mettre entre
toutes les mains
après pour y consacrer du temps à la
digestion entre autres et préférez les
gros plans ou les plus en plus large
moi je pense que les deux sont opaques
septembre ça ça dépend sur quoi
justement sur quelle partie du corps
vous êtes le courrier les groupes sur
envisage oui pourquoi pas des parties
plus intimement les parties bas en
général compte 10 les plus érotiques les
seins les fesses met les pieds
le sexe de l'homme de la femme préféré
que ce soit scénarisé ou pas c'est
l'arrivée un bien grand mot que ça veut
dire
on n'a pas tellement besoin de
l'histoire en fait celle et frustré car
on a besoin d'une histoire quand on
regarde un porno c'est pour voir du cul
c'est pas pour voir une histoire
quel style d'homme vous aimez voir dans
les émissions dites sexy ou dans les
films
bah ce qu'on voit en général grands
beaux sexy et compagnie au bas des
sommes assez viril
et en même temps intéressant bien membré
ou pas si elle choix de préférence pas
moi une espèce de centrales ou bien une
femme plus ou moins rondes et le style
botero enfin pas encore
tant qu'à faire assez grand c'est pas
plus mal puis voilà ça peut prêter
aucune chance vous laisse coi à savoir
avoir peut-être que vous allez manger la
soupe et grandir on sait jamais et
maintenant mesdames messieurs je
voudrais vous montrez larmes absolue et
avant de la diffuser de la tester sur le
public est présent ici au studio bonheur
[Musique]
alors est ce que vous pensez qu est ce
que vous pensez qu'on peut diffuser ça
aux téléspectateurs un samedi soir à
télévision
est ce que cette paix sa gamme style de
scènes trop soft trop soft et le samedi
c'est bien programmer maintenant trotter
tu veux quoi plus hard non vers sept
heures du soir à sept heures du soir
pourquoi on était fous mais non non il
faut apprendre à tout le monde que c'est
bon on peut le passer à penser qu'elle
est assez attention
ouvrez bien les yeux ça va durer cinq
secondes on ne repassera pas attention
2 3 c'est scandaleux service public
envoyez de la kuleuven les vivres
paradoxe encore de l'architecturé
vénitienne le palais ducal
la logique voudrait que tout l'édifice
safin
mais ça fait chier tout le monde venise
roland voyez pas que ça fait chier tout
le monde d'autres trucs de venise toutes
les semaines comme ça depuis le début
non ce que veulent les gens c'est du
sexe à télévision étatique
[Applaudissements]
allons-y
ça suffit rollin ça suffit outre venise
du sexe c'est ce qu'un bon goût ça
qu'est ce que veulent les gens corps le
plus sexy star
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas raisonnable thierry nous
sommes là en train de nous entre
déchirer sexe contre culture et nous
faisons le jeu de nos adversaires
l'ennemi le véritable ennemi c'est ceux
qui ne regardent par dix matches mais
c'est comme en politique la gauche et la
droite s'entredéchirent
mais le vrai ennemi c'est les
abstentionnistes c'est notre et demi
sont les gens qui nous regardent pas
pour une raison ou pour une autre ceux
qui vont au théâtre par exemple mais il
faut faire la guerre je suis assez
d'accord avec vos professeurs parce que
le théâtre finalement faut sortir par là
que faut payer quand on est au théâtre
on a envie d'aller pisser on veut pas y
aller on a envie d'aller chercher une
bière dans le frigo on peut pas et le
lendemain matin quand on arrive au
bureau à qui on en parle du théâtre
n'allez plus au théâtre regarder la télé
vise la télé par contre c'est formidable
ya des défis des records des
performances on va en avoir une ce soir
sur le plateau d'artistes une petite
fille petite fille qui s'appelle camille
et qui est capable de souffler 35
bougies sans reprendre son souffle dos
ce soir
bon vous elle va essayer d'en souffler
est ce qu'on peut faire rentrer khamis
il ajouté
ce soir c'est non
cliquez là
rien 10 en étuve à l'école à quelle
école le camp de l'arbalète l'école de
l'arbalète
ils font quoi tes parents tu sais pas tu
sais pas
alors tu es capable de souffler 35
bougies d'un seul coup tu vas essayer
d'en souffler 40 ce soir d'aller voilà
les bougies alors on va essayer un on va
poser les bougies à bien prendre ton
souffle 1 et tu vas nous souffler les 40
bougies d'un seul coup merci messieurs
attention tu es prête
est ce que dans le public vous pensez
qu'elle va arriver à battre ce record
[Applaudissements]
parce que tu peut l'encourager
bien sûr elle va pour toi battre ce
record et va souffler les 40 bougies
ouais oui on peut l'encourager
et
[Applaudissements]
attention ma petite camille tu es prête
on va compter au fur et à mesure on va
compter tous ensemble attention je vais
y aller à mon top tu y vas d'accord bien
que des tirs il le record du monde et de
quarante bougies je compte elle a
soufflé 0 bougies n'ont eu une une
bougie et bien elle n'a pas réussi leur
corps n'est pas battu du tout du tout du
tout du tout thierry c'est dommage si
c'est dommage pour nous c'est dommage
pour cet enfant et puis c'est surtout
dommage pour le chien et sur lui donner
encore une chance
[Applaudissements]
les seniors
allez attention attention va réessayer
attention on se concentre je te donne
top et un allez vas-y attention
professeur il va tirer je compte à
nouveau il fallait souffler 40 bougies
pour battre le record du monde
elle est parvenue à souffler une bougie
de zoologie
ce n'est pas suffisant le record n'est
pas battu du tout du temps me sebbar
avons applaudi quand même
j'ai donné beaucoup d'interviews et il
en donne encore beaucoup en ce moment à
l'occasion de la sortie de son dernier
album solo keith richards lui aussi a
donné beaucoup d'interviews parfois mick
jagger et keith richards ont accepté de
donner des interviews ensemble et puis
une seule fois mick jagger et keith
richards ont accepté de répondre
ensemble aux mêmes questions
voici le résultat
[Musique]
tout comme john monster ne reste impuni
célébrités donc il faut pour pots-de-vin
mais j'ai mes pensées des choses comme
ça au jeu laisser la lumière dans celle
de pain je suis comme ça au joli nom
il faut concentrer seulement sur la la
scène
pour qu'on se croise alors pourquoi cinq
minutes dont les futurs pouvoirs qu'est
ce qu'on va faire
[Musique]
m
tout y est
[Musique]
photo
key
[Musique]
m
what you say party
[Musique]
what you tube le magic notre village
ouah je veux être de 7 cm cuiseaux enfin
ou du live too big to fail
cléopâtre
quand wayne différentes visites mais
honni toualy millions $ owens technique
sur l'avion ni super six longueurs vous
êtes là mais il trouva très très
difficile lorsque l'on fait une émission
de télévision basket
lavialle basket non non non non mais
c'est incroyable ça c'est un vrai
scandale
on nous demande notre avis on le donne
et il va vous en tenez aucun compte
alors à quoi on sert là on fait tapis
c'est ça
jean pierre est calme toi tout le monde
nous regarde avait justement moi je
représente 30 millions spectateurs alors
je demande du basket viendra du basket
et bah vous nous voulons quoi ces
deux-là de la variété anglaise là c'est
un vrai scandale et mettez un peu de
basket on en a pas du basket bat bons
mots que j'ai présentées basque nord
montr par chantal lorsque lorsque l'on
fait une émission de télévision et
baskets
sache bien le basket ans qu'on le
demande c'est un vrai scandale ça on
nous demande notre avis on le donne et
vous en tenez aucun compte alors un
concert on est là pourquoi on fait
tapisserie sortir red planet what your
glass aimerait justement moi je
représente 30 millions téléspectateurs
et je demande du basket vous nous
envoyez là la variété anglaise la saint
vaast scandale ça n'est pas que de
quelle d'accords mets tes baskets mais
duquel jonas pas les baskets j'en aurais
mis si j'en avais tu penses
lorsque l'on bat on peut y aller oui oui
on y va à chantal lorsque l'on fait une
émission de télévision
on ne la fait pas que pour eux soit le
basket nous avions le basket est temps
qu'on le donne en basque est un vrai
scandale ça on nous demande notre avis
on le donne et vous n'en tenez aucun
compte
on est là pourquoi en fait tapisserie
alors je demande du basket il veut nous
envoyer la variété anglaise certains
quoi ça suffit maintenant ça suffit les
calais basket était midi parce qu est
née gens n'aiment pas du basket hockey
les téléspectateurs ça suffit on y va à
chantal lorsque l'on fait une émission
de télévision
on a fait pas de bons soirs le basket
mais il est recommandé du programme et
des choses que l'on aime vraiment
tenez prenez west side story pas la
première fois que j'ai vu ce film
c'était avec ma mère j'avais 12
[Musique]
au delà
[Applaudissements]
aline trede essonnois nogueira snake
eyes toi
my own and she wolf dans tout type cloud
mobile bada la commune america
[Musique]
la touche la mêlée
accès
la classe est nommé effet que fight in
america latina rail canada et monsieur
white america
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
et
[Musique]
ah la la
m
[Musique]
la mairie
oh
réplique à cobac tous un droit à nyon
est pathétique
dreamworks pictures
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
après les portoricains de new york en
1960 nul voici les mexicains
je laisse en 1990 une seule différence
ce ne sont plus george chakiris et rita
moreno qui danse mais les voitures de
notre communauté mexicaine la voiture
c'était mal costumes il suffit de
regarder une voiture on savoir si son
propriétaire d'un type qui a réussi dans
le business
et s'il a de l'autorité dans le
communautaire chicane nos voitures ce
sont des longs runs ont les trafics pour
qu'elles soient les plus basses
possibles
les amortisseurs hydrauliques sont
contrôlés par le conducteur
même si on ne s'intéresse pas à la
mécanique qu'à moi on est au courant de
ces choses là quand on vit ici
et puis ce que cherche surtout les
quitte à renoncer d'attirer l'attention
des filles
et ça marche moi par exemple j'adore
[Musique]
samedi soir toute la semaine j'ai
attendu ce moment là les garçons du
fonds du plan avec leur voiture et nous
aussi en sont nos armes de séduction
heart rate
ça c'est le cas encore la plus grande
compétition vainqueur sera celui qui
fera bondir sa voiture le plus haut
possible
barrot
mais les juges sont rarement objectif
lisant souvent des amis parmi les
participants alors sans plaît pas à tout
le monde et ça crée des tensions
mais l'important c'est de concourir est
de plaire jasper de la navette
[Musique]
vézina avant d'être une star du 7e art
marilyn monroe aurait tourné un film
porno c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme le
collectionneur amérique
nous a envoyé ce document inédit alors
marilyn ou pas marilyn a book
[Musique]
oh
ans
[Musique]
non
en
on
pour vous
auj
oh
bonsoir voila supplie rendez vous samedi
prochain en attendant vous retrouvez
olivier minne dans quelques instants
régie finale pour le commentaire des
résultats de vos appels télé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
peu de bleu